There's so much to look at and think about
in Disney's long-awaited sequel that it's
easy to overlook the many jokes, references,
and shoutouts hidden throughout.
Fortunately, we're here to help you make sense
of it all with this look at some of the best
and most memorable Easter eggs in Frozen II.
It's almost as obvious that Frozen II is a
Disney movie as it is obvious that it's a
movie about a queen with magical powers who
turns stuff into ice and belts out "Let it
Go" to make herself feel better.
Yes, the House of Mouse signed the paychecks
for all the animators and voice actors who
worked very hard to make Frozen II a dazzling
cinematic experience, and the crew said thanks
by dropping in a number of cute references
to Disney projects old and new.
The film begins with a pre-Frozen flashback
to Anna and Elsa as kids.
Although they live in a magical fairy tale
kingdom of yore, they do what kids of any
time would do: play with dolls.
But these dolls are made out of ice, courtesy
of Elsa's magical powers.
One of the figures is a little elephant with
a long trunk and oversized ears — Dumbo,
in other words.
A slightly hulking, rounded one is a dead
ringer for Baymax, the friendly robot from
the 2015 Disney/Marvel hit Big Hero 6.
There's also one who looks like adorable monster
Totoro from My Neighbor Totoro, a 1988 Studio
Ghibli film to which Disney controlled American
distribution rights.
"Merchandising!"
"Merchandising, what's that?"
Of course, the most recognizable character
in Disney's long history is Mickey Mouse.
Walt Disney's first successful creation is
so recognizable and so popular that the silhouette
of this high-voiced star of "Steamboat Willie"
is a linchpin of Disney's iconography.
Disney theme parks are full of "Hidden Mickeys"
— those three black circles that comprise
the mouse's head and big ears are real-life
Easter eggs to be found on the ground, walls,
and inside rides.
Just like Disneyland, Frozen II is sprinkled
with a few Mickeys.
During a game of charades, Olaf cycles through
several poses, one of which involves placing
coals on top of his head and one in his nose
region.
The clue he's acting out is "mouse," and he
chose to look like Mickey.
Later, when Elsa sings "Into the Unknown,"
she spins and leaves an ice circle in her
wake.
Very briefly, two circles appear atop that
circle, forming the well-known Mickey shape.
Tons of Disney animated movies, including
Sleeping Beauty, Snow White and the Seven
Dwarfs, Mulan, and Cinderella, are based on
folk tales, legends, and fairy tales.
Frozen is based on The Snow Queen, a story
first published in Danish in 1844.
The author, Hans Christian Andersen, also
wrote the source material for another Disney
classic, The Little Mermaid.
He laid the narrative groundwork for Frozen,
but Frozen II was created entirely by modern-day
screenwriters imagining new adventures for
the characters inspired by Andersen's.
The author's presence is still felt in Frozen
II, however, as an affectionate passing reference.
Toward the end of the movie, audiences see
a flashback to when Elsa and Anna's parents
— Iduna and Agnarr — were children.
Iduna runs over to Agnarr and inquires about
the book in which he's happily engrossed.
He explains it's "a new Danish author."
He means Hans Christen Anderson.
Pixar is a wholly-owned subsidiary of Disney,
so Disney distributes Pixar films such as
Toy Story, Cars, and Newt.
Oh, you haven't heard of Newt?
That's because it's a long-lost, unfinished
project.
Announced in 2008, Newt was about the world's
last male and female blue-footed newts that
must breed to save their species, only they
don't get along.
Pixar had no choice but to cancel the film
— Fox's 2011 release Rio hit theaters first,
with virtually the same plot as Newt, except
it was about macaws.
Frozen II just may have paid homage to this
forgotten obscurity.
One of the cutest new characters introduced
in the film is a big-eyed magical salamander
named Bruni who can spread fire the way Elsa
spreads ice.
He bears more than a strong resemblance to
the newts introduced in the concept art of
the ill-fated Newt.
The original Frozen was a massive hit.
Upon its release in 2013, it earned $1.2 billion
at the box office.
And it's full of memorable songs — "Do You
Want to Build a Snowman" and the Oscar-winning
"Let It Go" especially — so adapting Frozen
into a Broadway musical, like The Lion King
and Aladdin before it, was a no-brainer for
Disney.
The live version of Frozen opened in 2018
and earned three major Tony Award nominations,
including one for Best Musical.
Co-starring in the challenging role of conflicted,
heartbroken young Anna in that production:
actress Mattea Conforti.
When Frozen II producers put its cast together,
they brought Conforti on board.
In a subtle Easter egg that only the most
hardcore of Frozen franchise fans were likely
to notice, the former young Anna gave voice
to young Elsa in Frozen II.
Apart from Elsa and Anna's epic quest, Frozen
II also finds Kristoff wrestling with his
romantic situation.
His relationship with Anna is seemingly so
solid that he wants to propose marriage, but
every time he gets a chance to pop the question,
he messes it up.
Before long, he wonders if he and his love
are drifting apart, and he expresses these
feelings in a big musical number called "Lost
in the Woods."
It's performed in the style of a 1980s power
ballad, and the sequence makes use of the
kinds of things one would see in a vintage
'80s music video.
Kristoff voice actor Jonathan Groff explained:
"It's sort of for the adults.
It's a joke for the adults.
The little kids don't really get it."
"Were you living your best animated life doing
that?"
"I was living my best animated life."
There's also one very specific reference to
a well-known video from the 1970s.
The face of Kristoff, partially shadowed against
a black screen, appears in the bottom of the
screen, while three reindeer, singing backup,
show up in the top half.
It's a visual straight out of Queen's "Bohemian
Rhapsody."
Frozen II is surprisingly dark and emotionally
raw for a Disney cartoon aimed at grade-school-age
kids.
It finds Elsa and Anna coming to terms with
their family's history and legacy, while Olaf
the goofy snowman seems to be going through
an existential crisis brought about by aging
and being able to live in environments other
than snow.
When Elsa heads out into the Enchanted Forest
to find the source of a creepy voice only
she can hear, Anna, Kristoff and Olaf come
along, too.
For a few moments, Frozen II turns into a
road movie, with the gang piling into a reindeer-drawn
cart.
Olaf tries to help pass the time and entertain
his friends by reciting a seemingly endless
litany of fun facts of varying levels of truth.
He's having so much fun he doesn't care if
anybody wants to hear them or not.
This whole sequence is a pretty faithful re-creation
of the famous scene from the 1996 dramedy
Jerry Maguire, in which Jerry and Dorothy
patiently listen to Dorothy's son recite trivia
bits like,
"Jerry, Did you know the human head weighs
eight pounds?"
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
movies are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.